why doesn't our periodic table go on
forever why don't we have for example
elements with 300 protons so say a th000
protons well the short answer is because
heavier the elements the more unstable
they become for example elements about
um atomic number 83 they don't even have
a stable isotope all their Isotopes are
radioisotopes which means sooner or
later these will Decay and if you
consider even heavier elements well they
will Decay almost instantly and there's
no chance that they exist in nature but
why are they unstable in the first place
and how do they undergo dek and how do
we use this to create smoke
detectors let's find out so let's start
by asking ourselves why do heavy nuclei
become unstable in the first place well
the answer is because there are two
forces of nature act play over here
which are acting against each other the
first one is the good old kums repulsion
the electric force all the positive
protons are repelling against each other
this is what tries to blow the nucleus
apart but then what keeps the nucleus
together in the first place Well turns
out there is a force even stronger than
that the strong nuclear force and this
force is an attractive force and that's
what keeps the nucleus together and it
does so because strong nuclear force has
two advantages over the electric force
the first one is it is the strongest
force of nature so that's amazing but
there's another one you see the kum's
repulsion the electric repulsion is only
between the protons because it's only
between charged particles neutrons do
not participate right however when it
comes to strong nuclear force both
protons and neutrons participate so
they're all involved in the nuclear
strong nuclear attraction this is why a
lot of stable nuclei exist in our nature
because the strong nuclear attraction
just overpowers the electric repulsion
or the kums repulsion but compared to
the electric force the strong nuclear
attraction has one
disadvantage that is it is a short
ranged Force what does that mean well if
you concentrate on just say one proton
then it is being repelled by all the
other protons in this nucleus regardless
of how far the other protons are because
electric forces are long ranged it
doesn't matter how far they are the
electric force works and so it's being
repelled by all the other protons but
the nuclear force is short ranged this
means even though it is super strong and
everything um only the few protons and
neutrons in its vcinity they are the
ones in its neighborhood they're the
only ones that can attract it the ones
that are far away well they can't reach
it their nuclear forces are short ranged
now for lighter nuclei this is not a
problem because it is very small so most
of the protons and neutrons are within
the nuclear range but what happens as
the nucleus gets heavier well just
imagine an extreme case if there were
lots and lots of protons and neutrons
all the protons will repel it so the
electric force becomes incredibly large
on this proton but not all the particles
are going to attract it only the ones in
the neighborhood are going to attract it
which means if you have too many
particles and the nucleus is too big
eventually electric force will overpower
our strong nuclear force and that's what
will make it unstable and so now
hopefully you can see how or why as the
nucleus becomes more and more heavier it
becomes bigger and bigger and because of
the short range nature of the nuclear
force eventually electric force can win
out that's what makes these things
unstable so if you now imag imagine
elements with thousands of protons
there's no chance that they will stay
put the electric force will just blow it
apart it'll just break
instantly but what about the heavy
elements that we do have in the periodic
table well over here the strong nuclear
force can sort of kind of hold on to
them but not forever they have found a
way to become more stable how well they
just spit out a helium nucleus and we
call this the alpha DK we call it the
alpha DK because when we first
discovered it we didn't know which this
particle was what particle this was and
we just called it the alpha particle but
later on we realized that it's just a
helium nucleus with two protons and two
neutrons okay this might raise a lot of
questions now the first question could
be how does this make thing make things
stable well you can see the daughter
nucleus now has less particles in it so
it's slightly smaller than the parent
nucleus if it's smaller it's that much
easier for the strong nuclear force to
hold on to it and therefore it becomes
more stable than the parent nucleus now
that is doesn't mean that this is
completely stable this might still be a
radioisotope and it might further
undergo more Alpha DEC which is totally
possible okay but then a followup
question that comes to my mind is why a
helium nucleus why not anything else why
does it spit out precisely this well the
short answer is because helium nucleus
is incredibly incredibly stable and so
it's just more energetically favored and
therefore that's what happens okay
another question we could have is When
Things become stable the energy
decreases right this should now have
less energy compared to the parent
nucleus that's what it means to be
stable but if that's the case where did
the energy go well that energy comes out
as the kinetic energy of these particles
the alpha particle will take up most of
the kinetic energy but the daugh nucleus
will also have some recoil as well and
now guess what these alpha particles can
go and hit other atoms make them jiggle
causing Heat this is how radioactive
heating works and fun fact folks we
believe this is majorly what keeps the
Earth's core prettyy hot I mean there
are some other reasons but we think this
is the major one and another fun fact
this is where most of the helium on our
planet comes from from the radioactive
DK of elements found inside the earth
anyways let's now familiarize ourselves
with this and take a couple of examples
one example could be uranium 92 turns
out it will undergo an alpha decay the
question for us is what happens after
the alpha dekay can we predict what the
daughter isotope would look like well
let's see here's how I like to think
about it I know if it's an alpha DK then
a helium nucleus com comes out therefore
my daughter nucleus must have two less
protons in it it started with 92 protons
two less protons which means that
daughter nucleus should have 90 protons
in it similarly uh my daughter nucleus
will now have four particles Less in
total it started with 238 now it has
four particles less that means it should
now have
234 particles in it that should be its
new mass number so my new my daughter
nucleus should look like this but what
is it I don't remember which what is the
element it's not uranium anymore because
it is 90 and I don't remember you don't
have to remember that's where we have
that's why we have the periodic table if
I just look at the periodic table I see
902b over here so this is
Thorium thorium so look we get a new
element Al together and if you look at
the periodic table you can see we've
gone from uranium to thorium so that
means we hop two to the left in the
periodic table that kind of makes sense
because you're losing two protons so you
hop two elements to the left okay why
don't you try one in this example let's
say there is some parent nucleus that
undergoes an alpha DK and gives you
neptunium
93237 can you pause and predict what the
parent nucleus be it's it's you know
it's atomic number and the mass number
when you pause and
try all right again it's an alpha DK so
I know a helium nucleus must have been
thrown out therefore I can now predict
well there is 93 in the daughter two
came out so the parent had to have 93 +
95 protons in it and similarly four came
four particles came out 237 is in the
daughter nucleus that means the parent
must have had 237 + 4
241 total number of particles in it and
therefore my my parent nucleus would be
having an atomic number 95 which is over
here am am stands for am
and so there you have it that's my
parent nucleus and again you can see if
you look at the periodic table after the
alpha DEC we've gone two elements to the
left of the periodic table so you see
all we have to do is keep track of total
number of protons and neutrons they stay
the same because nothing is changing the
total number of protons and neutrons
here will be the same as the total
number of protons and neutrons here and
if you keep track of that we'll be able
to predict what our daughter nucleus
would be or what our Paran nucleus would
be now there is a reason why I took this
example because this is the radio
isotope used in smoke detectors but how
does alpha DK help us detect smoke let's
see the heart of these radioactive smoke
detectors will contain two plates
connected to a battery so that they have
a positive and a negative charge and you
have the amarium source at the bottom
now the amarium is going to give out a
lot of alpha particles but so far did
you notice something about the alpha
particles they have two protons in them
but they don't have any electrons
because they came from the nucleus
which means alpha particles have a plus
two charge on them and since they're
moving with a high speed they can now
knock off a lot of electrons from the
atmospheric particles over here from the
oxygen nitrogen and all the other atoms
and that's why we'll now end up with a c
of electrons and positive ions now of
course the helium nuclei will eventually
pick up electrons and become neutral
atoms but eventually they leave behind a
lot of positive and negative charges as
a result this whole thing becomes a
conductor now and therefore there will
be a current a continuous current
running in the circuit now this process
where the helium nucleus is able to
knock off electrons is what we call
ionization and that's why we call Helium
to be highly ionizing radiation but
anyways what happens when we have smoke
well it disrupts this process it doesn't
allow the helium to ionize a lot of
these atoms anymore because of the smoke
particles in between that significantly
reduces the current and that is sensed
by a sensor
in the circuit and the alarm goes off
this is how alpha DK can be used to
detect smoke I find this absolutely
mindboggling but you might be concerned
thinking that we have a radioactive
element in our house now isn't that
dangerous well in general radioactive
elements are dangerous but here's the
thing about alpha particles sure they
are extremely ionizing however they
don't go very far they can be easily
stopped Say by just a piece of paper
because they're so bulky and therefore
although they have a high ionization
power they have very low penetration
power and that's why none of the alpha
particles will even leave the casing of
your smoke detector and so you don't
have to worry about anything but what if
you decide to Now open up the smoke
detector to have a closer look at the
amarium well now that can be dangerous
because you might have some neptunium
237 lying around somewhere over here
floating around you might ingest it
neptunium is also radioactive and
therefore now you have radioactive
elements inside your body that can be
dangerous so don't do that